hey girl let's go cheetah
Oh what is it that lovely thank you for
that I'm so happy all right then what
what is that whoa whoa
one the way what is it the crazy black
magic that's going on here there's some
weird stuff happening and I don't much
appreciated hate chubster what's up bro
what's up bro what's up right huh you
even lift bro you even left with your
weird eyes breath huh bro you want to go
with me huh toe to toe bro too bad for
you yeah
nothing that's right mr. butt crack whoa
you gotta be so gross
whoa whoa whoa whoa mega fatty can make
a move I had no idea no no no no no no
no no se away stay away stay away hey
dodged a big toe she's so creepy weird
uh why do they got to be so weird
Rosy's oh geez oh gosh you have the
homie chats they used to have that and
then they took an arrow to thee
why do I gotta suck it's been a while
Bungie God oh I did horribly hang on I
get you're better than that one second
by the way death is permanent and
whatnot yes yes yes oh god no no no
never fish no no you're looking at a
wall you big goof come on it's not upon
the who Isaac glimpse of yeah we'll be
blinded by the moon right in the tough
your noggin